bboys breakdancers whatever you want to
call them if you're looking for the best
look no further than South Korea
these answers aren't just popular
they're influencing culture throughout
the country boyo Cuddy I'll go with a
person them not all can go until tonight
even with all these I witness this is
b-boy skin and this is P boy wing
reasonably Mila and their brothers or a
subtenant Oh Hank CBS hi Jo Angela's a
catchy tune go hotshot snicker in the
Chilean yagi tokachi aqua clicker hammer
toe toe you got some questions about
alchemy the members of the jinjo crew
one of the best breakdancing groups in
the world John Bonham hair so Baltimore
hey so the question is from capture
student tariqa ahsoka on Monday it has
okay basil terrible training Yagami Das
Keyboard interior chop on Rizzo Crandall
a Madonna trailer cut with matatini
let's break down some moves the basic
start with a top rack are the opening
dance then you move to footwork where
the dancer is supported only by their
hands or feet the work builds into flow
techniques and flow techniques build up
to power moves like the Flair and the
head spin these moves take years to
master people Johnny chart an emboldened
go circle somewhere Tona zone is a
wooden toy Li for yourself since Obamas
omggg work as I watch commander jewelry
you will choke at the member with a
charitable Tommy look at you my child
that was no
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]